This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一档iHeart播客。保证真人。嗨，大家好！欢迎收听《艰难抉择》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。这个节目探讨黑人的经历，进行那些在其他地方绝对无法坦诚交流的对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着一副盔甲？这向世界传递出的信号是：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着你必须时刻戒备。来吧，从节目中汲取经验，
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你收听播客的任何地方搜索并收听《艰难抉择》。2023年，前《黄金单身汉》嘉宾克莱顿·埃克哈德（Clayton Echard）被指控令人生下双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。“你篡改了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？”“我篡改了一次测试。”这需要大批网络侦探出动，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人：格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱的陷阱》（Love Trapped）。“劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。”随着节目的深入，劳拉·欧文斯终于自食其果。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你收听播客的任何地方收听《爱的陷阱》播客。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个光怪陆离的现代世界中，关于心理韧性、健身和培养抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即英文数字TWO的谐音，可在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你收听播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子交往过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说，
that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s, and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world.
相信你的闺蜜。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你收听播客的任何地方收听《相信闺蜜，相信我，宝贝》（The Girlfriends. Trust me, babe）。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十多岁的心理学》（The psychology of your 20s），在这个播客中，我们探讨二十多岁时面临的一些重大生活变化和转型，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到本播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落，
I am so glad to have you here for an episode for a topic I'm really, really passionate about. It is possibly one of my strongest opinions. I don't even think it's a controversial one. I want to talk about why I believe so deeply that one of the best things we can do in our 20s is full in love with our own company. And I want to talk about why that is, but more specifically how we can do that, especially in a world where we are more addicted to social contact and engagement, stimulation than ever before when I think actually having a moment of true
我非常高兴你能来收听这一期节目，探讨一个我真的、真的很热衷的话题。这可能是我最坚定的观点之一。我甚至不认为这是一个具有争议的观点。我想聊聊为什么我坚信，我们在二十多岁时能做的最好的事情之一，就是爱上独处的时光。我想谈谈这是为什么，但更具体地说，我们该如何做到这一点，尤其是在这样一个世界里——我们比以往任何时候都更加沉迷于社交接触、互动和感官刺激，而我认为，事实上，真正独处的时刻变得越来越稀少。
solitude is increasingly rare. It's still very much possible. And I think, It's a necessity if you want to deepen the relationship that you have with yourself and as a result, the people around you. Honestly, I think every aspect of your life becomes more defined and sharper and intentional when we value our own free time and our own company. And we see that space and that time being alone with ourselves as a source of peace, as a source of contemplation and growth, rather than just as empty space that we need to fill with social commitments, with work, with anything of the sort. I think it comes back to that very core foundational philosophy we have on the show, that the relationship you have with yourself is your biggest and most important investment.
但这依然非常可能做到。而且我认为，如果你想加深与自己的关系，并进而加深与周围人的关系，这是必不可少的。老实说，我认为当我们珍视自己的空闲时间和独处时光时，你生活中的每一个方面都会变得更加清晰、敏锐和有目的性。我们将独处的时间和空间视为平静、沉思和成长的源泉，而不仅仅是需要用社交承诺、工作或诸如此类的事情去填补的空白。我认为这回到了我们在节目中一直秉持的核心基础哲学：你与自己的关系是你最大、最重要的投资。
And when you neglect it, I think everything else in your life tends to suffer as well. No one can sustain you, can know you, like you know yourself. and so you have to make that relationship a priority, even when it's not easy, even when it's not convenient, even when it doesn't come naturally to you. So I have always had, I think, a really complicated relationship with loneliness just to get vulnerable for a second. And I think it really stems quite honestly from being bullied as a child. I was a really strange kid. I didn't have many friends. I was always kind of made to play like the villain character when we were playing make believe, I was a bit shy. I was just a bit different, which is something that I love
而当你忽视它时，你生活中的其他一切往往也会随之受损。没有人能像你自己那样支撑你、了解你，所以你必须把这段关系放在首位，即使它并不容易，即使它并不方便，即使它不是你的天性使然。因此，为了剖析内心的脆弱，我觉得自己与孤独的关系一直以来都相当复杂。而且我认为这真的坦白说根源于我小时候遭受的霸凌。我是一个真的很奇怪的孩子。我没有多少朋友。当我们玩过家家时，我总是被当作坏人角色，我有点害羞。我只是有点与众不同，而现在我很喜欢这一点，因为我认为奇怪的孩子会变成有趣的大多数。但因为在我年轻、塑造性格的那些年里，有一整段时期，我从未真正觉得自己属于哪里，我从小就知道孤独是什么感觉。
now because I think weird kids turn into interesting adults. But because there was this whole period in my younger years, in my formative years, where I never quite felt like I belonged, I knew what it felt like to be quite lonely from a young age. And I did get really comfortable with my own company. It was like kind of a bit of a superpower for myself. As sad as it sounds, right? Like, you know, I get that it's very kind of yet sad. Like you didn't have enough friends, so you had to be your own best friend. And I really actually valued that about myself. But when I got to uni, I've spoken about this before, but I really met my people. I got to meet the people I still call my best friends even now. And of course, it was like the best thing ever. This is what I always wanted. But because this was
我也确实对独处感到非常自在。这对我来说就像是一种超能力。听起来可能有点悲伤，对吧？就像，你知道的，我明白这确实有点让人难过。就像你没有足够的朋友，所以你不得不成为自己最好的朋友。我其实真的很感激自己这一点。但当我上大学后，我以前也说过，我真的遇到了志同道合的人。我遇到了那些直到现在我依然称之为挚友的人。当然，这就像是世上最棒的事。这就是我一直想要的。但因为这是一段
such a new experience to constantly have people I wanted to be around who made my life. so much better who were really tired to me at the hip for a long time. I kind of forgot how to be alone. You know, that survival skill, that protective mechanism, I developed of valuing my own company was no longer useful in this situation, so I neglected it. And eventually, it was something that I had to relearn, especially as I transitioned kind of out of my early 20s when I was at uni and I was surrounded by people all the time to the situation I'm in now where I was working full time. I moved to a new city where I didn't have as many friends. I was suddenly single as well. It felt so similar to how I had felt as a child. But I had lost my coping skill.
全新的经历，身边总是围着我想与之相处、让我的生活变得如此美好的人，他们很长一段时间都跟我形影不离。我有点忘记了如何独处。你知道，那种生存技能，我为了珍视独处而培养的保护机制，在这种情况下不再有用了，所以我忽视了它。最终，这是我不得不重新学习的一项技能，尤其是当我开始告别二十出头、身处大学且身边总是围满人的时期，过渡到我现在的情况——我全职工作，搬到一个朋友不多的新城市，而且突然间又单身了。这感觉和我小时候的感觉太像了。但我已经失去了应对的技能。
I had lost I think the reverence and the joy I felt in my own company. And I really kind of began to notice that the reason this was so difficult, this transitionary period, was because for the last three or four years before that time, I hadn't really put any effort into the relationship I had with myself. I was always prioritizing time and experiences with others, and it eventually came at my detriment. I think as a generation, all of us included, we have a hard time spending time alone for a few reasons. The biggest contributor is FOMO, the infamous fear of missing out. And the fear of missing out is twofold. Firstly, it involves a perception followed by a compulsion. So we really tend to exaggerate the quality and the fun. We think everybody else is having without us.
我失去了那种对独处时光的崇敬与喜悦。我真的开始注意到，这段过渡期之所以如此艰难，是因为在此之前的整整三四年里，我根本没有为自己与自己的关系付出任何努力。我总是优先考虑与他人相处的时间和经历，而这最终损害了我的利益。我认为作为一个代际群体，包括我们在内的所有人，由于种种原因，都很难独自度过时光。最大的罪魁祸首就是FOMO，也就是臭名昭著的“错失恐惧症”（Fear Of Missing Out）。而错失恐惧症具有两重性。首先，它涉及一种感知，随之而来的是一种强迫行为。因此，我们真的倾向于夸大没有我们参与时，其他人正在享受的品质和乐趣。
So in those moments when we're not present, we really tend to like expand what we think other people are experiencing. And we tend to make it seem a lot bigger and more golden and colorful than it actually is. And this results in us never wanting to miss an event, never wanting to be without plans or excluded, which is a compulsion, right? we are kind of compelled to constantly be engaged and constantly be involved almost as a way to soothe that fear that we're missing out. Now, it should be noted that this term, FOMO, was first introduced in 2004. That is the same year that Facebook launched. And it began to really take off in like the early 2010s as a direct consequence of this increasing uptake of social
所以在那些我们不在场的时刻，我们真的倾向于放大我们认为其他人正在经历的事情。而且我们倾向于让它看起来比实际情况大得多、美好得多、也丰富多彩得多。这导致我们永远不想错过任何活动，永远不想没有计划或被排挤在外，这是一种强迫行为，对吧？我们某种程度上被迫不断参与、不断融入，几乎以此来抚平我们正在错失什么的恐惧。现在需要指出的是，“FOMO”这个词最早是在2004年被提出的。那正是Facebook上线的那一年。而在2010年代初，随着社交媒体的使用率不断增加，它开始真正流行起来，
media and the opportunities it provided for people to constantly see what others were up to and to compare that to their own days and their own lives. Now more than ever, at this point in society, we are exposed to so many details, intimate details about what others are doing. And that means that we're faced with this continuous uncertainty about whether we're doing enough, whether we are getting enough social connection, whether we know as many people as we should, whether our friendships are as successful as we would want them to be. So I think it kind of makes socialising quite competitive. And if our aim is to always be as busy as the next person and never let those negative feelings of FOMO into our lives, then we do really deprive ourselves of the opportunity
社交媒体为人们提供了源源不断的机会，让他们随时了解别人在做什么，并将其与自己的日常和生活进行比较，这是社交媒体直接导致的后果。现在比以往任何时候都更是如此，在当今社会，我们接触到了太多关于别人在做什么的细节，甚至是极其私密的细节。这意味着我们不得不面对一种持续的不确定性：我们是否做得够多？我们是否获得了足够的社交连接？我们认识的人是否和我们应认识的一样多？我们的友谊是否达到了我们所期望的成功程度？所以我觉得这让社交变得相当具有竞争性。如果我们的目标永远是和别人一样忙碌，绝不让那些FOMO的负面情绪进入我们的生活，那么我们确实剥夺了自己的机会，
and the beauty of cherishing our alone time. Researchers also believe that. that FOMO makes us particularly attuned to feelings of social rejection, whether that social rejection is perceived or real. And we know that on a psychological and emotional level, that the pain of rejection really mimics the same kind of discomfort. We feel in response to physically painful stimuli and injury. So we want to avoid it. But missing out on plans won't ruin your life. It won't immobilize you the same way that a broken arm or a fraction leg will. If you are someone who freaks out at not having plans on a Saturday night or spending even a single evening alone, I think it's really time to consider whether this is actually genuine loneliness, whether you actually need more social
以及珍惜独处时光的美好。研究人员还认为，FOMO使我们对社交被拒的感觉特别敏感，无论这种社交被拒是主观感受到的还是真实存在的。我们知道，在心理和情感层面，被拒绝的痛苦确实模拟了我们在面对身体疼痛刺激和伤害时感到了那种不适。所以我们想要避开它。但错过一些安排并不会毁了你的生活。它不会像断臂或骨折那样让你失去行动能力。如果你是一个在周六晚上没有安排或者哪怕独自过一个晚上都会抓狂的人，我认为这真的是时候考虑一下这究竟是真正的孤独，你是否真的需要更多的社交连接，
connection, or whether it's FOMO and you just need to reframe your relationship with your own company. I think it also comes down to the fact that as a society, we just don't have a healthy relationship with loneliness. We see it as something to avoid. We stigmatize it. We fear it. Rather than actually holding space for it in our lives and recognizing what it firstly has to teach us. Secondly, how universal it is. And thirdly, how it can actually help us cultivate a richer and I would say deeper in a world.
还是其实是FOMO作祟，你需要重新构架你与自己陪伴的关系。我认为这归根结底还在于，作为一个社会，我们对孤独并没有建立起一种健康的联系。我们把它视为需要逃避的东西。我们给它贴上污名。我们对它感到恐惧。而不是真正在我们的生活中为它留出空间，并认识到它首先能教给我们什么，其次它是多么普遍，第三它实际上如何帮助我们培养更丰富、我可以说更深刻的内心世界。
Loneliness, let's get this straight. like it is just a cue from your body. The same way that hunger is telling you it's time to fuel, it's time to eat. Thirst is telling you it's time to drink, fatigue, tidness are telling you it's time to rest. Loneliness is telling you that it's time to connect. Or it's time to sit with yourself and figure out why it is that you feel that way. It's also important to note that the more we excessively socialize, the higher our threshold for satisfying social connection becomes, the more we need.
说实话，孤独，让我们搞清楚这一点。它其实只是你身体发出的一个信号。就像饥饿在告诉你该补充能量了、该吃东西了，口渴在告诉你该喝水了，疲劳、困倦在告诉你该休息了。孤独在告诉你，是时候去建立联系了。或者，是时候和自己坐下来，弄清楚你为什么会有这种感觉。同样重要的是要注意，我们过度社交的次数越多，我们对满足社交连接的阈值就会变得越高，我们需要的也就越多。
Kind of think about it. this way, right? At high school, you saw your friends every single day, most likely. And one day apart felt really strange. When we get into our 20s, especially our later 20s, our level and our capacity for seeing other people naturally goes down a bit. But if you have become, if it's become very difficult for you to spend time alone, if you're so used to having people around you constantly, the more that you sustain the urge to like book out your calendars, to always be around people, to never have a moment for yourself, the less you're able to tolerate the times when you do have to enjoy your own company. You know, there will be periods in life where you are lonely. But if you have
换个角度想想，对吧？在高中时，你几乎每天都能见到你的朋友。分开一天都会觉得很奇怪。当我们进入二十多岁，尤其是二十多岁后期，我们见到其他人的水平和容量自然会有所下降。但是，如果你已经变得——如果花时间独处对你来说变得非常困难，如果你习惯了身边总是有人，如果你越是压制不住那种把日程表塞满、总是和别人在一起、绝不让自己有片刻独处的冲动，你就越无法忍受那些不得不享受自己陪伴的时光。你知道，生活中总会有你感到孤独的时期。但如果你从未给自己机会去感受那种情绪，去适应那种状况，去接受在一段时间内做一个有点孤僻、但快乐的独行者，
never given yourself the opportunity to feel that way, to adjust to that situation, to embrace being a bit of a loner, a happy loner for some time. When you do eventually find yourself in that period, in that chapter, in that season of loneliness, it's going to be so much more difficult. I think on a more general level, we also fail to kind of appreciate the value of our company because of societal and cultural expectations that really emphasize the importance of social connection. And it is really important, right? This isn't like a denial of the value of friendship or the value of having somebody to talk to or having somebody to catch up with, it's more so that with our increasingly busy lifestyles and the constant barrage of
那么当你最终发现自己身处那个时期、那个篇章、那个孤独的季节时，一切将会变得困难得多。我认为在更广泛的层面，我们也未能欣赏到独处价值的另一个原因，是社会和文化期望过分强调了社交连接的重要性。这确实很重要，对吧？这并不是否认友谊的价值、与人交谈的价值或与人聚会的价值，而是说，随着我们日益忙碌的生活方式和来自科技源源不断的感官刺激，这使得我们很难慢下来并真正享受独处，因为我们习惯于——并且倾向于——将独处等同于无聊和没有生产力，而作为人类，我们并不太擅长应付这些。这些并不是我们轻易会接受并作为生活一部分的情感。所以这确实引导我走向了我的主要观点，在这个核心，在这个分心最容易发生的当今时代，当你不想经历时就绝不需要经历沉默或独处的日子里，
like stimulation from technology, it can make it really difficult to slow down and actually enjoy solitude because we have, and we tend to equate being alone with being bored and being unproductive, which are things that as humans were not quite quite. You know, we're not very good at managing. Those are not feelings that we're readily going to accept as part of our lives. So this really leads me to my main point, really, at the center of all this, at the core, in this day and age when distraction is the easiest thing you can do, when you really never have to experience silence or solitude if you don't want to.
爱上自己的陪伴，是我们能找到的最彻底的自我同情与成长的行为之一。这并不是最容易做到的事。在一个周六的晚上待在家里写日记、画画或阅读，独自去电影院，独自去散步，这并不总是（你知道的）最有趣的事情。这确实需要牺牲，也确实需要纪律。我们不能否认这一点。但当你真正了解自己的那种方式——我是说，当所有的屏幕都关掉，当只有你和你的空间时，我认为，
Falling in love with your own company is one of the most radical acts of self-compassion and growth that we can find. It isn't the easiest thing to do. It isn't, you know, the funnest thing to do always to, like, stay in and journal or paint or read on a Saturday night to go to the movies alone, to go for a walk on your own. It does require sacrifice, and it does require discipline. Let's not deny that. But the way you get to know yourself, and I mean really know yourself on all the screens
那真的相当深邃。一开始感觉糟糕透顶，当你克服这种不适感之后，就会变得妙不可言。你会发现自己有点上瘾于独处，在大多数日子里，这实际上成了你的首选。我想正是从那时起，我们真正看到了其中的好处。我想花一点时间谈谈这些。所以，当一组研究人员坐下来深入研究这一课题时，他们希望观察那些积极花更多时间独处的人，与那些要么刻意回避独处、要么根本没有机会独处的人进行对比。这些人有孩子。另一个例子是在军队或海军服役的人。
are off when it's just you and your own space, I think. that's really quite profound. And it is awful at first as you kind of work through the discomfort and then it's magical. And you'll just find that you're kind of addicted to your own company, that it actually is your first choice most diets. And I think that it's then that we really get to see the benefits. And I want to talk about those for a second. So when a group of researchers sat down to have a look into this, they wanted to observe people who actively spent more time in their own company compared to those who either shy away from it or who just don't have the opportunity. These people have kids. Another example was people who worked in the military or in the
所以他们一次离开三、六个月。他们周围总是被其他人包围。宿舍里的人。这些只是几个例子。然后他们将这些人与那些，如我们所说，真正优先考虑独处或只是能够花更多时间独处的人进行对比。因此，拥有更多独处空间和时间的人表现出了更高水平的内省。他们更珍视自己的独立性，也更具创造力。创造力这一方面实际上是我非常着迷的地方。我真的被这一论点的这一要素所吸引。我记得当我经历刚才谈到的那段孤独和隔离期时，特别是当我刚搬到悉尼的时候。我从未如此富有创造力。我在休息的夜晚画画。我像疯了一样写日记。
Navy. So they go away for like three, six months at a time. They're constantly surrounded by others. People in dorm rooms. Those are just a few examples. And then they compared them to the people who, like we said, really prioritized or were just able to spend more time alone. So the people who had more space and time for themselves displayed a greater level of introspection. They valued their independence more and they were more creative. The creativity aspect is actually something I'm really drawn to. I'm really attracted by that element of this argument. I remember when I was going through this like period of loneliness and isolation I was just speaking about, especially when I first moved to Sydney. I had never been more creative. I was painting on my nights off. I was journaling like crazy.
我有些最美妙的文字就是在那时诞生的，是在那些独处的时刻写下来的。因为我能看电视的时间真的很有限。在我真正想要做一些有生产力、有表现力的事之前，我刷手机的次数也是有限的。当你珍视自己的陪伴时，你会拥有这种不被打断的专注力。你还拥有了白日梦和任由想象力驰骋的心理空间。这就是为什么那么多作家要进行这种独自隐居的旅行来完成他们的手稿、完成他们的书，因为独处时间对于我们创造力的蓬勃发展至关重要。所以这就是主要的论点，我认为：更多的内省，更多的独立性，
Some of my most beautiful entries ever were then, were written in those moments of solitude. Because there really was only so much like TV I could watch. There was only so much scrolling I could do before I actually wanted to do something productive and expressive. You have this uninterrupted focus when you value your own company. You have also the mental space for daydreaming and for letting your imagination run off. It's why so many authors go on like these solo retreats, trips to finish their manuscripts to finish their books because alone time is so important for our creativity to thrive. So that is the main argument, I think, more introspection, more independence,
更多的创造力。爱上自己陪伴的另一个巨大好处是，你不会让别人来定义你和你的经历。我认为，当我们变得过于依赖他人来获得认同感或兴奋感，以填补我们白天的空白时——也许是出于对无聊或孤独的恐惧，这实际上赋予了他们在我们和我们的决策上很大的权力。现在，并不是说他们一定会滥用这种权力。并不是说他们在操纵它。只是在无意中，他们对我们的情绪产生了影响，
more creativity. The other huge benefit of falling in love with your own company is that you don't let others define you and the experiences that you have. I think when we become too reliant on others for a sense of validation or excitement to fill the empty space we have in our days, perhaps out of a fear of boredom or loneliness, it actually gives them a lot of power over us and our decision making. Now, it's not that they are necessarily going to exploit that power. It's not that they're manipulating it. It's just that involuntarily, they have an impact on our emotions
因为我们将自我感和情绪与我们能见到人的时间、他们的可及性以及我们接触他们的便利程度紧密地联系在了一起。如果我们见不到足够的人，我们真的会注意到情绪和心理健康的巨大变化。而当我们珍视自己的陪伴时，别人取消计划其实也无所谓了。
because of how much we tie our sense of self and our mood to when we're able to see people and their availability and the access that we have to them. If we don't see people enough, we can really notice huge changes in our emotions and in our kind of mental well-being. Whereas when we value our own company, it doesn't really matter if people cancel plans.
别人很忙或者被工作缠身也无所谓，因为和自己一起消磨时间同样是一个极好的替代方案。这方面的另一个体现是我们独自做事情的能力。在我们的愿望清单上有很多事情，有很多我们想做的事情，说实话，我们绝不会考虑一个人去完成。你知道，独自旅行就是一个很好的例子。
It doesn't matter if they're busy or they're caught up with work because hanging out with ourselves is like an equally good alternative. The other aspect of this is our ability to do things alone. there are a lot of things that we have on our bucket list, a lot of things that we wanted to, that let's be honest, we would never consider doing by ourselves. You know, traveling solo is a big example.
但在更小的层面上，一个人去看电影，一个人去听音乐会，去那家新餐厅。这些往往是我们希望有别人陪伴才能完成的事情。但是，自己一个人去经历这些事情会带来无与伦比的快乐。我也认为，当我们因为——我不知道，也许是感到尴尬或其他原因——而无法忍受一个人去做这些事情时，通常这意味着我们错过了。我们看不到那些风景。我们没有那些经历。我们没有去那些我们想去的地方，因为如果没有另一个人在那里，我们就无法做到。
But then on a smaller level, going to the movies alone, going to a gig by yourself, going to that new restaurant. Those are things that we often want the company of others to do. But there is so much joy in having those experiences by yourself. I also think that when we can't tolerate doing those alone because we're, I don't know, maybe embarrassed or whatnot, often that means that we miss out. We don't see those things. We don't have those experiences. We don't go to those places that we want to go because we can't do it without somebody
因此，这有点像你的体验是由别人的存在来决定的。除非你很幸运，有很多一呼即应的朋友，否则我认为，如果你总是等着别人觉得这是个好主意、或者陪你一起去、或者你试图说服他们，你实际上正在做的事情，又一次是根据是否有人能陪你来决定你的经历，而不是基于你是否真的想去，而不是基于你是否知道自己会玩得开心并且能够独自完成。我认为我们必须学会爱上自己陪伴的最后一个原因，
else there. And therefore, it's kind of like your experiences are determined based on somebody else's presence. And unless you are blessed to have a lot of yes friends, I think that, you know, if you're always waiting for somebody else to think it's a good idea or to come with you or you're trying to sell them on it, what you're actually doing is determining your experiences yet again based on whether somebody else can come with you rather than based on whether you just want to go, rather than based on just whether you know that you're going to have fun and you can do it alone. I think the final reason that we have to learn to fall in love with our own company,
特别是在我们现在二十多岁的时候，是因为它具有极好的保护作用。现在，我之前稍微提到过这一点，但总有一天你会感到孤独，当一段恋情结束时，当你的朋友们都很忙或不在身边时，如果我们从未练习过在没有任何人陪伴的情况下如何快乐地生活，那么我们生活中的那些时刻可能会格外痛苦，因为我们不知道该如何与自己相处。我常常认为，我们对孤独的恐惧，以及我们无法欣赏独处的自由和快乐，有时会让我们留在明知不合适的恋爱关系中，仅仅因为我们太依赖别人来让我们觉得自己被看见，或者来击退我们对孤独或无聊的恐惧。但是，你知道，
especially in our 20s right now, is because it is so protective. Now, I spoke about this a little bit before, but there will come a time when you are lonely, when a relationship ends, when your friends are all busy or away, and if we have never practiced being happy in those circumstances when nobody else is present, those times in our lives can be particularly agonizing because we don't know what to do with ourselves. I often think that our fear of being alone and our inability to appreciate the freedom and joy of our own company sometimes keeps us in relationships we know aren't working just because we are so reliant on others to make us feel seen or to fight off our fear of solitude or boredom. But, you know,
问题是，当那段感情正在破裂，当你明知无法与那个人在一起，当火花消失，当浪漫不再时，如果我们无法离开，仅仅是因为我们太害怕孤独，那该怎么办呢？你知道，我经常听到人们发出疑问：为什么人们还不分手？为什么他们不直接甩了他？为什么他们不继续过自己的生活？我认为，对孤独的恐惧以及所有那些空虚的时间和空间，正是让我们留在那些关系中的原因。这有点像：当这个人不在身边来掩盖这些声音时，我会产生什么样的想法？我在生活中一直忽视了什么，而这些现在又要浮出水面了？当我独自躺在床上，当我周五晚上坐在沙发上时，
The thing is, is that when that relationship is failing, when you know that you can't be with that person, when the spark is gone, when the romance is gone, what if we can't leave because we're just too afraid of being alone? You know, I often think people question like, why do people stay? Why don't they just dump him? Why don't they just move on with their lives? I think a fear of being alone and all of that empty time and empty space is what's keeping us in those relationships. It's kind of like what kind of thoughts am I going to have when this person isn't there to drown them out? What have I been ignoring in my life that is going to come to the surface? What fears do I finally have to confront when I am laying in bed alone, what I am sitting on my couch on a Friday night,
周围没有人来分散我的注意力，我最终必须直面什么恐惧？这种恐惧的解药是知道在自己的内心深处，你永远不会孤单。你拥有数百万、数十亿、数万亿的神经连接、通路、记忆和秘密角落去探索，它们随时对你开放。你拥有这样一个丰富的内心世界，它专属于你，而且它是如此美妙。你可以让自己发笑。你可以给自己带来无限的幸福和快乐。你可以对好奇并对自己保持善良。
and there is nobody there to distract me? The antidote to that fear is knowing that you're never going to be alone in your own mind. You have millions, billions, quadrillions of neural connections and pathways and memories and secret corners to experience that are always accessible to you. You have this rich inner world that is just for you and that is so wonderful. You can make yourself laugh. You can bring yourself immense happiness and joy. You can be curious and kind to yourself.
你可以靠自己让生活变得有趣。事实上，如果在这里引入另一个心理学理论，我们会发现一件很有趣的事：当我们谈到物质财产时，我们往往更珍视自己拥有或属于我们的东西，而不是那些不属于我们的东西。这是一种被称为“禀赋效应”（endowment effect）的偏差。举个例子，假设你有一双非常喜欢的鞋子，你花70美元买的，但对你来说它们价值100美元左右，对吧？所以有人可能会说：“我出80美元买下它们”，这比你买的时候花的钱还多。但对你来说，因为它们属于你，因为它们对你很特殊，所以它们更有价值。然而，我们的大脑真是太奇怪了。它在一种情况下表现出某种行为，而在下一种情况下又自相矛盾。
You can make life interesting on your own. and it's fascinating actually just to bring in another psychological theory here into this that we often tend to value the things we own or which are ours more than the things that we don't when it comes to our material possessions so it's a bias called the endowment effect to say for example you have a pair of shoes that you absolutely love and you bought them for 70 but for you they're worth like a hundred right so somebody could be like I'll buy them for 80 which is more you bought them for. But for you, because you own them, because they're special to you, they're worth more. But our brain is so weird. It acts one way in one circumstance and then contradicts
我们似乎并不像珍视他人那样珍视自己的陪伴，对吧？所以这有点像是：好吧，你会花50美元和自己一起消磨时间，还是花100美元和朋友一起出去玩？人们总是会说：“嗯，我想和朋友一起出去玩。”尽管我们自己的陪伴才是我们最应该觉得宝贵的东西。不过话说回来，你可以通过有意识的行为和练习，重新塑造你的大脑，使其优先考虑那些独自体验和独处时间。这就是我接下来要讨论的内容。我们有哪些切实可行的方法，能够真正爱上自己的陪伴，
itself in the next. We don't seem to value our own company as much as we value others, right? So it's kind of like, okay, would you pay $50 to hang out with yourself or $100 to hang out with your friends? People are always like, well, I want to hang out with my friends. Even though our own company is the thing that we should feel is the most valuable. Once again, though, you can rewire your brain into prioritizing those solo experiences that alone time through like intentional behaviors and practices. So that's what I want to discuss next. What are the actual ways, practical, tangible ways we can fall in love with our own company
并拥抱我们能给予自己的一切呢？好了，在经历这段短暂的广告休息之后，我们将讨论所有这些以及更多内容。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个光怪陆离的现代世界中，关于心理韧性、健身和培养抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家等展开对话，带大家看透那些充斥着健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾以为种子油本质上具有炎症性。
and really embrace all the things that we can give ourselves? Well, we're going to talk about all of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即英文数字TWO的谐音，可在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你收听播客的任何地方收听。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（戳）小肯姆（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？还是坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不关心黑人。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim?
好吧，你可以在播客《回头看》（Look Back at it）中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特（Sam Jett）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。在每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·hill（Mark Lamont Hill）的访谈，他大谈特谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为……快克。
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of... crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know.
我随时准备在任何一天聊聊快克，只是为了让你们都知道。我的意思是，马克，到了这个时候，这已经是我们讨论快克的第二期节目了。所以我开始看出这里有一条贯穿始终的线索。现在我们还把“艾滋病”这个话题摆上了台面。谢谢你把那句话说完。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你收听播客的任何地方收听《回头看》。欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难抉择》，我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了致敬心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾进行的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we
没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在这个世界上做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人只是因为你害怕？
don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid?
因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你只是真正地去做一个好人。和我基尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《艰难抉择》中，就治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标进行真正的对话。
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way.
打开你免费的iHeart Radio应用，搜索“Learn the Hard Way”并立即收听。2023年，前《黄金单身汉》嘉宾克莱顿·埃克哈德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家事法庭听证会暴露出她说法中前后矛盾的明显漏洞。这引发了一场长达数年的法庭之战，以证明真相。“你篡改了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？”“我篡改了一次测试。”这需要大批网络侦探出动，才得以破案。
Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learning a hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
我想让人们看到他们的税款都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭露了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人：格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alespian）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱的陷阱》。
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap.
“劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。”随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。“女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。”在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你收听播客的任何地方收听《爱的陷阱》播客。无论我们的独处是自愿的——也就是说我们刻意优先安排自己的独处时间，还是非自愿的，
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice is. served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Whether our alone time is voluntary, so we are intentionally prioritizing our solitude or involuntary.
你知道，你其实很希望能和别人一起闲逛，但你却发现自己一个人过了一整晚，或者处于一段与世隔绝的时期。如果你不习惯这样做的话，你可能无法一开始就享受独处的乐趣。你必须把它当作一种仪式，几乎像是一种精神体验，或者是一件为了你的身心健康而去做的事情。就像你在一个星期里抽出时间去看朋友，或者抽出时间去锻炼一样，你需要抽出时间来独处。最简单的方法是选择一个晚上，或者周末的一大块时间——一个上午或下午，专门留给自己。这就像你每周和自己开一次无法更改的例会。
You know, you really wish you were hanging out with people, but you found yourself alone for the evening or in a period of disconnect. You're not going to come out of the gates, I think, enjoying your own company if it's not something that you're used to. You have to treat it like a ritual, like an almost, kind of like a spiritual experience or a thing that you do for your well-being. The same way that you find time during your week to see your friends, or you find time to exercise, you need to find time to be alone. The easiest way to do this is to choose either one evening or like a chunk on the weekends, a morning and afternoon that is reserved just for you. It's like you have a stand-up meeting with
对其他人感到抱歉，你已经有安排了，这是没有商量余地的。对我来说，我通常把周一的晚上留给自己，因为我觉得我的社交电量在周末已经被压榨空了。周一通常是我最忙的一天，因为这一天我要录制播客，就像我现在正在做的一样。所以我把这个晚上留给自己。我有一个既定的日常。我总是去健身房，然后听我最喜欢的播客《这个美国生活》（This American Life）。他们会在周一发布新节目，所以我听那个。然后我，我是一个小插曲。我不是。然后我，我总是去健身房。我是一个去健身房的人。我听健身房的。我听健身房的。我去桑拿房，好吧，说实话，我健身房的桑拿房现在闻起来怪怪的，
yourself each week that you can't shift. Sorry to everybody else, you have plans, it's non-negotiable. For me, I normally take Monday evenings to myself because I feel like my social battery has already been like spiked by the weekend. Mondays are normally my busiest day because it's when I record a podcast, literally what I'm doing right now. And so I take the night for me. I have an established routine. I always go to the gym and then I listen to my favorite podcast, This American Life. They drop their new episodes on Monday, so I listen to that. Then I, I'm a little episode. I'm not. Then I'm, I always go to the gym. I'm a gym. I listen to the gym. I listen to the gym. I I go to the sauna, which, okay, I'm going to be honest, the sauna at my gym smells at the moment,
里面好像还有蟑螂侵扰。但是，你知道，过了一会儿，你根本分不清那是你自己的汗水还是别人的，所以其实也没那么恶心。不管怎样，好吧，扯远了。然后我进行我的“全套沐浴”（everything shower）。我给自己做一顿最喜欢的饭菜。类似于红薯沙拉。然后我看《摩登家庭》（Modern Family）或者当时正在追的任何剧。到了八点钟，这一点至关重要：我关掉设备，选择做一些能让我感到充实而不是被动接受的事情。通常，那会是阅读、写日记或画画之类的事，我在唱片机上放上音乐，然后让自己在那儿坐一会儿。你知道，如果我——我不需要不停地写作或阅读。有时我老实说只是坐在
and there's like a cockroach infestation. But, you know, after a while, you can't tell whether it's your sweat or somebody else's, so it's not that gross. Anyways, okay, tangent. I then do my everything shower. I make myself like my favorite meal. It's like the sweet potato salad. And I watch Modern Family or whatever show I'm, you know, on at the moment. And at eight o'clock, this is crucial. I switch off and I choose to do something that is going to fill my cup that is not passive. Normally, that is something like reading or journaling or painting, and I put music on my record player, and I just let myself sit there for a bit. You know, if I, I don't need to be like constantly writing or reading. Sometimes I just honestly sit on my
沙发上发呆，让自己做做白日梦，任由思绪飘荡。没有人等我，没有什么事要做，我不需要打电话给任何人，因为这是我为自己预留的时间。在这个过程中，你可能已经注意到，我做的每一件事都是我真正喜欢做的事。我最喜欢的播客、我最喜欢的饭菜、我最喜欢的节目、我最喜欢的活动。那是因为享受自己的陪伴，听起来很简单，意味着当你这样做时，确实要去做一些你喜欢的事情。同样地，去做一些真正滋养你的事情。你可能会认为，当你洗衣服或去杂货店买东西时，就是在享受独处时光。这其实仍然是非常宝贵的时间。
couch and just stare into space, and I let myself daydream and I let my mind wander. There's no one waiting on me, there's nothing to do, there's no one I need to call, because this is like, the time that I've reserved for me. Within that, what you may have noticed is that everything I do is something I actually like doing. It's my favorite podcast, my favorite meal, my favorite show, my favorite activity. That's because enjoying your own company, as simple as it sounds, means actually doing something you enjoy while you're at it. And equally, doing something that is actually nourishing. You might think that you're spending alone time and enjoying your own company when you're doing your laundry or at the grocery store. And it is still really valuable time,
沙发上发呆，允许自己做白日梦，让思绪飘飞。没有人等我，没有什么事要做，不需要给任何人打电话，因为这是我为自己保留的时间。在这个过程中，你可能已经注意到，我做的每一件事都是我真正喜欢做的。这是我最喜欢的播客、最喜欢的饭菜、最喜欢的节目、最喜欢的活动。那是因为享受自己的陪伴，听起来很简单，意味着在独处时真正去做你喜欢的事。同样，也要做一些真正能滋养身心的事。你可能会认为，当你洗衣服或在杂货店购物时，你是在度过独处时光并享受自己的陪伴。这确实仍然是非常宝贵的时间，
but it's not necessarily, you know, meaningful time. It's labor, it's chores. Unless you're someone whose hobby is cleaning, I think there is a difference between really, like, consciously being like, this is going to be a time and an evening where I feel my own cup. And this is just like an activity that I just have to do alone. So let's just call it my alone time. I think the same way that you, you would really want to spend quality time with your friends or your boyfriend or your girlfriend. You need to do the same with yourself. If your entire relationship, you know, with your partner, for example, consisted of sitting in front of the TV or lying in bed and scrolling mindlessly on TikTok next to each other, that is not quality time with your partner. Your relationship would
但这不一定是有意义的时间，你知道的。这是劳动，是杂务。除非你的爱好就是打扫卫生，否则我认为，真正有意识地觉得“这将是一段让我感到充实、滋养的时光和夜晚”与“这只是一项我必须独自完成的活动”之间是有区别的。所以，我们不妨把它叫做我的独处时间。我觉得，就像你真的很想和你的朋友、男朋友或女朋友共度高质量时光一样，你也需要对你自己这样做。如果你的整段关系，比如你和伴侣的关系，仅仅包括坐在电视机前，或者躺在床上，在一旁毫无目的地刷着TikTok，那这并不是与伴侣的高质量时间。你的关系会
suffer. You never would really connect or deepen your bond because you're distracted. You're doing something mindless. So why do you expect the relationship you have with yourself to not suffer if you're doing the same thing? If every time you have a moment to yourself or an afternoon with no plans, you spend it in a way that is quite passive or draining. Now this isn't to say that sometimes we don't benefit from just brain rot. Like my boyfriend calls it scratching his lizard brain when we just, we've had a hellish day. Work has been really tough. We just want to switch off for a second and watch like some garbage TV. That is honestly so valuable. But if that becomes your norm, the status quo of how you spend time with yourself, I think you're missing out on some of the
受到影响。你们永远无法真正连接或加深纽带，因为你们分心了，在做一些不用脑子的事情。那么，如果你对自己的独处也这样做，为什么你还期望你与自己的关系不会受损呢？如果每一次你拥有属于自己的时刻，或者一个没有计划的下午时，你都是以一种相当被动或消耗精力的方式度过它。这并不是说有时候我们不会从单纯的“大脑放空”中受益。就像我男朋友所说的，当我们经历糟糕的一天、工作非常辛苦、只想关掉大脑一会儿、看一些垃圾电视时，这叫“抓挠他的蜥蜴脑”。老实说，这非常有价值。但如果这成为了你的常态，成为了你与自己相处方式的现状，我想你将错过一些
other really rich and deep experiences and things that you can do during that period that would be maybe more valuable. So this brings me to this exercise, this idea, this concept of ritualizing your alone time so that it's something that you are looking forward to. I have a friend who does this really, really well. And I have to give them a shout out in this episode because if everybody that I have in my life, they spend their alone time the best. They love their own company the most. And the way that they have kind of learnt to do this, because they weren't always like this, was to have a date night with themselves once a month. They choose a different Italian restaurant in Sydney. They get a glass of wine and they get a bowl of pasta. And of course they dress up for themselves because it's
其他非常丰富、深刻的体验，以及在这个期间你可以做的、可能更有价值的事情。所以这就引出了这个练习、这个想法、这个将独处仪式化的概念，让你开始期待它。我有一个朋友，这件事做得真的非常好。我必须在这期节目中向他大喊大叫，因为在我认识的所有人中，他把独处时间过得最好。他最喜欢自己的陪伴。而他学会这样做的过程——因为他以前并不是这样的——是每个月给自己安排一次约会之夜。他在悉尼选择一家不同的意大利餐厅，喝一杯葡萄酒，吃一盘意面。当然，他会为自己精心打扮，因为这是
date night. You have to look nice. You have to play the part. And then they sit there on their own and they ask themselves the same five questions in like a specific journal they have just for this purpose. The five questions are, what did I do today and how am I feeling about myself? What's something I'm looking forward to? What's one thing that I've been proud of recently? What's on my mind and what is one thing I want to change in the next month. I think that this is such a sweet practice to do, to really like find time one evening in the next 30 days that's just for you where you were at the center.
约会之夜。你必须看起来很好，你必须扮演好这个角色。然后他独自坐在那里，在一个专门为此准备的日记本里，问自己同样的五个问题。这五个问题是：我今天做了什么，我对自己的感觉如何？我期待的是什么？我最近引以为豪的一件事是什么？我脑子里在想什么？以及我在下一个月想改变的一件事是什么。我认为这是一种非常甜蜜的做法，真的能在这30天里找到一个专属于你的、以你为中心的夜晚。
You are consciously thinking about your life. You are consciously dating yourself, spending time with yourself, being intentional about where you're going, but also kind of finding a way to, I don't know, not worship yourself, I think that's excessive, but celebrate who you are and your progress and what's going on. And it's just fun. Like, it's actually really fun to just have this like little ritual that you do all for yourself, to dress up for yourself, to go and just like kind of splurge on a nice meal. The same way that you would do that for others, right? When you're dating people,
你在有意识地思考自己的生活。你在有意识地和自己约会，花时间陪自己，对自己的去向保持笃定，同时也找到一种方式，我不知道，不是去崇拜自己，我觉得那有点过头了，而是去庆祝你是谁、你的进步以及正在发生的事情。这很有趣。实际上，拥有这样一个全属于你自己的小仪式，为你自己盛装打扮，去挥霍一顿美味的餐点，真的非常有趣。就像你对别人做的那样，对吧？当你和别人约会时，
when you're going to see your friends, you know, you make time for them that is quality time. You look nice for them. You spend more money. than you want to for them, you can do that for yourself. Another way I think to really sink deep into your own company is to just do stuff alone, even if no one wants to come with you. Now, we spoke about this before, but if you want to see that movie, if you want to go to that comedy show, if you need to buy new jeans, if you want to go out for breakfast and no one's around, great, you're around, you're free,
当你去见朋友时，你知道，你会为他们留出高质量的时间。你会为他们打扮得漂漂亮亮。你会花比你原本想花的更多的钱为他们付出，你也可以这样对待自己。我认为，真正深入感受自己陪伴的另一种方法就是：即使没有人愿意跟你一起，也自己去做那些事，哪怕没人陪。我们之前讨论过，如果你想看那部电影，如果你想去那个喜剧演出，如果你需要买条新牛仔裤，如果你想出去吃早餐而周围没有人，太好了，你在，你是自由的，
off you go. I think this feels, you know, quite awkward at first, especially when we become so accustomed to the presence and the noise of others in our lives. But I think that one thing that really does hold us back is thinking that we're going to be judged as well. I promise you, no one is looking that closely. And even if they are, human memory is very fallible. And it's very short, they aren't going to remember you.
出发吧。我觉得这一开始感觉挺尴尬的，尤其是当我们习惯了生活中其他人的存在和喧嚣时。但我认为，真正阻碍我们的其中一件事，是觉得我们会受到评判。我向你保证，没有人会看得那么仔细。退一步说，就算他们真的在看，人类的记忆也是非常不可靠的，而且非常短暂，他们根本不会记住你。
And to just add to that, the only time I think I've ever noticed people who are doing things alone, like at dinner alone or at a cafe alone, at a movie alone, is when I've been thinking about how much I admire them for something that it's taken me years to do. I'm like, wow, you must be a really cool person. Like, there's some really amazing power in this action that you're doing in this choice. When you do feel the twinge of loneliness that I think is only human and natural sometimes, I think that it's important to take a moment to just notice it and to observe it. And I mean, make your loneliness like a physical presence, like a little character in your mind or a butterfly in front of you, and just watch it move through your space. This like fluttering object. That's your
不仅如此，我想我唯一一次注意到有人独自做事情——比如独自吃晚餐、独自在咖啡馆、独自看电影——是我在想，我有多么崇拜他们能做出这种我花了多年才敢做的事。我想，哇，你一定是个很酷的人。你在做这件事、做出这个选择时，有一种非常惊人的力量。当你确实感到一丝孤独时——我认为这在有时是完全人性化且自然的——重要的是花一点时间去注意到它、观察它。我的意思是，让你的孤独变成一个实体，比如你脑海中的一个小角色，或者你面前的一只蝴蝶，然后看着它在你的空间里移动。这个飘动的物体，就是你的
loneliness. It's not going to hurt you. It's just there. It's just fluttering about. You don't have to respond or react and eventually it will fly off and bother somebody else. If we squash anything that makes us skittish or fearful or uncomfortable, we shut off from a lot of the world. You lose out. Like you genuinely do if you're always motivated by something that you fear and that means that you avoid circumstances that would activate that fear. For example, you're afraid of feeling lonely so you never take the risk to, I don't know, go to that country by yourself or go out for dinner.
孤独。它不会伤害你，它只是在那里，只是在四处飘动。你不必回应或反应，最终它会飞走去打扰别人。如果我们压制任何让我们胆怯、害怕或不舒服的东西，我们就会把自己从广阔的世界中封闭起来。你会失去很多。如果你总是被恐惧驱动，并且这意味着你会刻意避开那些会激活这种恐惧的环境，那你确实会失去很多。例如，你害怕感到孤独，所以你永远不敢冒险——我不知道——独自去那个国家旅行，或者独自出去吃
dinner on your own. That's not doing the thing that's best for you. That's doing the thing that fear wants you to do. So finally, instead of the fear of missing out, I think we need to switch to the joy of missing out. I'm sure you've heard this phrase before, but it's a concept that I love. It was originally introduced to me by Tanya Dalton. She's an author who wrote, like the ultimate guide on this. If you look her up, her book is amazing. And Jomo, the joy of missing out is basically like the emotionally intelligent and like mature antidote to FOMO. And it's essentially about being present and being content with where you're out in your life, focusing on what you gain by saying no to plans, by switching off,
晚餐。那不是在做对你最好的事，那是在做恐惧希望你做的事。所以最后，与其害怕错过（FOMO），我认为我们需要转变为享受错过（JOMO）。我确信你以前听过这个词，但我非常喜欢这个概念。最初向我介绍这个概念的是塔尼亚·道尔顿（Tanya Dalton）。她是一位作家，写了关于这方面的终极指南。如果你去查一下她，她的书非常棒。JOMO，也就是享受错过，基本上就像是治愈FOMO的情商高且成熟的解药。它本质上关乎活在当下，对你目前的生活感到满足，专注于通过对计划说“不”、关掉设备、
what you gain by ignoring the needs of others and the need to compare and think about what, you know, everyone's expecting from you. And just really noticing how much peace it brings you to just do what you want to do. I think the older we get, the more we understand the joy of missing out, like, as a concept. You know, we understand the joy of a friend cancelling the plans that we made when we had a lot more energy. And we understand the joy of getting to set our own agenda, to choose what we want for dinner, what we want to do without evenings, to choose to reply to messages when we want to, rather than feeling like we always have to be engaged and clocked in and locked in with other people.
通过忽视他人的需求以及比较的需求来获得什么，去思考每个人对你的期望是什么。并且真正去注意到，只做你想做的事能给你带来多少平静。我认为我们年龄越大，就越能理解“享受错过”这个概念。你知道的，我们理解当我们的精力其实没那么多时，朋友取消了我们之前定好的计划所带来的快乐；我们也理解设定自己的日程，决定晚餐吃什么、在夜晚做什么，以及想回信息时再回信息，而不是觉得自己必须时刻与他人保持联系、打卡和绑定，所带来的快乐。
There is immense beauty in that, and there is also a lot of freedom. I think sometimes we think that if we're not constantly present with others that they'll somehow forget about you. Trust me, they won't. They won't. A few missed evenings, a few rescheduled plans, a few times you say, sorry, I can't make it. I actually think that it's going to do more for your friendship, right? Because the time that you do spend together is very much quality time. You're really engaged.
这其中有着巨大的美感，也有着很多的自由。我想有时候我们认为，如果我们不时刻陪伴在别人身边，他们就会莫名其妙地把你忘了。相信我，他们不会的。绝对不会。几次错过的夜晚，几次重新安排的计划，几次你说“抱歉，我去不了”，实际上这对你的友谊更有益。因为你们真正相聚的时间绝对是高质量的时间，你们是非常投入的。
You feel like your own cup is full rather than kind of running on empty and feeling very much at the behest of your plans, feeling very much responsible to others rather than to yourself, first and foremost. So I think the final reminder, the final thing to take from this is the relationship you have with yourself is your biggest investment because it is the only one you will have alongside you, your whole life. You are spending every single second with yourself. That might feel like quality time, but sometimes you really need to have a check-in and be like, okay, do I like where I'm at? Am I enjoying who I am when nobody else is around? Can I find the fun in my own company? And my hope is that firstly you see that that's a valuable thing and
你觉得自己是被滋养的，而不是精疲力竭，也不是完全受制于你的计划，觉得对他人负有责任，而不是首先对自己负有责任。所以我想，最后的提醒、从中学到的最后一件事是：你与自己的关系是你最大的投资，因为它是唯一将伴随你一生的关系。你把每一秒钟都花在了自己身上。这可能感觉像是高质量的时间，但有时你真的需要停下来检查一下，然后问自己：“好吧，我喜欢我现在的处境吗？当周围没有其他人时，我享受做自己吗？我能在自己的陪伴中找到乐趣吗？”我的希望是，首先你看到这是一件有价值的事，
secondly that you do find the joy and the love in your own company. So thank you so much for listening to today's episode. I actually hope that you got something out of this. I hope that it's convinced you or persuaded you to adopt these rituals and this technique and this appreciation. for yourself because you're a lot of fun and you can have fun with yourself and you can laugh at yourself and you can bring joy to your own life without needing other people. As always, if you did enjoy this episode, share it with a friend and make sure that you're following along by hitting that follow button on Spotify or Apple Podcasts wherever you are listening. It really does help the show grow.
其次，你确实在自己的陪伴中找到了快乐和爱。非常感谢大家收听今天的节目。我真的希望你们能从中有所收获。我希望它能说服你或劝说你，去采纳这些仪式、这种技术，以及对自己的欣赏。因为你很有趣，你可以和自己一起玩乐，你可以自嘲，你不需要别人就能为自己的生活带来快乐。一如既往，如果你确实喜欢这一集，请把它分享给朋友，并通过点击Spotify、Apple Podcasts或你正在收听的任何平台上的关注按钮来保持关注。这确实对节目的成长很有帮助。
So as leaving a five-star rating, it helps other people find us, it helps expand the community and it helps me out. So if you do get joy out of this, if it is part of the ritual that you have for spending time alone or just part of your daily life, I would really, really appreciate it. And as always, we are always looking for new ideas, episode suggestions, feedback, discussions, contributions over on Instagram. You can follow us at that psychology podcast. We would obviously love to hear from you. And until then, until our next episode, stay safe, be kind to yourself, and we will talk soon. Hey, what's good, y'all?
留下五星好评也是如此，它能帮助其他人找到我们，有助于扩大社群，也能帮我大忙。所以如果你从中获得了乐趣，如果它是你独处仪式的一部分，或者只是你日常生活的一部分，我真的非常非常感激。一如既往，我们一直在Instagram上寻找新的想法、节目建议、反馈、讨论和投稿。你可以关注我们“That Psychology Podcast”。我们当然很期待听到你们的声音。在此之前，在我们的下一期节目之前，请注意安全，善待自己，我们很快再聊。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with.
欢迎收听《艰难学到的教训》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人科尔·加姆斯（Kear Games）。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在其他地方绝对不安全的坦诚对话，而你是在和一个懂得怎么做的持证专业人士一起交流。有多少男人穿着一套精神铠甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不好惹。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the outside, Hi-Hard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in selling, correct? I doctored the test ones.
而且，仅仅因为你具备这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学到的教训》。2023年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下一对双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试报告来售卖，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love, Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
这需要大批网络侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人的遭遇。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alesspian）。我整个人惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱，劳拉》，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hard. and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱被困住》（Love Trapped）播客。2%。这就是在也有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难，
Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target.
你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。这个名字写作数字的“2%”。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。
He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的好闺蜜。听闺蜜的话，相信我，宝贝。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。